has the white house given up our
president says yup
on wednesday as the average price of gas
climbs to five bucks president biden
basically shrugged admitting food and
gas prices won't be coming back to earth
anytime soon
wow if only there was someone who could
do something about that
i don't know like maybe the president
there's a lot going on uh right now but
the idea we're going to be able to you
know click a switch
bring down the cost of gasoline is not
likely in the near term nor is it with
regard to food
gee whiz joe no one expected
there to be a switch
just a white house that saw these
problems coming and instead of killing
pipelines actually creating more and not
less fuel
and that was said in an event meant to
highlight the action biden's taking to
reverse the baby formula shortage
something he should care about since
he's about six months away from being a
regular customer
[Music]
but even there he admits he was awol
even though he was worn ahead of time
[Music]
um
god help us
what an irony
our babies are relying on an infantile
adult
at least he didn't say there wasn't a
switch to turn on the baby formula
pipeline but if there was he'd probably
shut it down
time to wean ourselves off baby formula
meanwhile treasury secretary janet
yellen admits she also effed up
i think i was wrong then about
the path that inflation
would take as i mentioned there have
been unanticipated
and large shocks to the economy i didn't
at the time didn't fully understand but
we recognize that now
well better late than never
she wasn't so hot i demand she be fired
anything to add joe
all right some of these things i i
that formula thing i mean i i don't know
about that look they say there's not
enough formula maybe there's too many
babies do you ever think of that
right what are all these babies doing
and uh
you know what do they do anyway i mean
they can't do anything they can't
protest they can't vote for me they
can't pay taxes i mean come on
and they're getting older so pretty soon
they're not gonna need that drink that
stuff so problem solved
so life is gonna suck and we can't even
get excited about summer movie season
because now
there's also a popcorn shortage
so get used to seeing stuff like this
wow i can only imagine how much
popcorn's gonna be with all the
shortages don't worry how bad can it be
hi guys what can i get for you
uh large popcorn sorry we just have one
size how much that'll be two dollars oh
all right in that case we will take two
there you are
thank you
i'm still hungry aren't you hungry
uh-huh
wow i can only imagine how much
popcorn's gonna be with all the
shortages
[Music]
nice
charis
now it's popcorn
it's
armageddon are we heading towards
armageddon no i just our dear sweet
president i think if he thinks he
whispers they won't they'll stop asking
questions
my kids do that yeah who broke the hooky
well we see what happened
[Laughter]
and that's what happened
[Laughter]
clearly this administration hates babies
but it feels like children are in charge
it does feel like children are in charge
yes and they hate babies too i would too
i was a child hey and our president may
be the biggest child of them all a white
house aide told cnn a few a little
before we came to air uh he has to speak
about various serious things and you
can't do that while getting ice cream
yeah so this is what a white house aide
is saying about the president who by the
way his press secretary sake tries to
clean up the mess says we've been
working on this for months new press
secretary comes in korean jean-pierre
kjp she says we've been working on this
since day one and then biden's like oh
they didn't tell me until april what yes
your white house is trying to cover for
you and you're like the robber who tells
on yourself like that's a lie
[Applause]
um
cat as a financial expert yourself and
congratulations on the new fbn show cat
knows finances
i think people would watch that they
would watch that they'd get advice they
wouldn't get anywhere else that is true
um what do you make of this is are you
worried
at all you love baby formula
and popcorn sometimes you'll just put
baby formula and popcorn in a blender
won't you
you know me so well
yeah i mean obviously you can predict
this and i'm not that upset about this
as i am just you know the existence of
the fed yeah
what causes all of this because humans
are going to get it wrong and humans are
going to get make mistakes so we
shouldn't have them trying to control
the market because they can't
all right rand paul jr
or is it ron paul that was more ron he
was like the he was the good one ron
paul jr he was the good one he was the
one who was like an actual libertarian
all right thank you you're welcome any
time
nerd
such a nerd
i'll take that over heroin user all
right
[Laughter]
you can be both reach for the stars
last word to you chris what say you uh
has there ever been a white house where
the president is less interested in
doing the job yeah like honestly like i
hate to be the person who says can you
imagine if trump can you imagine trump
standing before the american people and
saying
nothing i can do about it yeah
no one told me
didn't know this thing where'd it come
that's just gonna be
what do you say like no no hey by the
way he would have had all the baby
formula makers march their butts into
the white house and would have said what
do we got to do to ramp up production
tomorrow you tell me now what you're
gonna do
it would have been like this
got the baby formula it's the best
best baby formula ever there would be
trump baby formula
a lot of people talking about
it are talking about many people are
saying babies love it can i get my old
job back
it's like deja vu yes yes yes the babies
they can't stop talking
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else